so they give us a diagram here and they
give us this given that angle six is
congruent to angle seven and then we
want to prove that angle five is
congruent to angle age so first things
first the Givens you want to think of
those as clues or hints okay
so they give us that clue or hint to
help us along so that we can then go
ahead and prove this if we didn't have
any information whatsoever we wouldn't
have anything to go on we wouldn't have
a starting point but again think of the
Givens as clues or hints and what I like
to do is I like to jump into the diagram
okay and mark it up so that I kind of
see you know Hollis is gonna all play
out so angle six is congruent to angle
seven so I'm gonna actually mark these
with the same marking so that when I see
it you know visually I can just know
right away that they're equal without
having to read it or remember it in my
mind okay so that's a good suggestion is
to mark the diagram the second thing
that I do is I try to figure out how I'm
going to prove this using the diagram
before I even get into the two columns
over here on the left and let's take a
look here well it looks like we don't
know that you know lines LNM we don't
know if they're parallel or not okay but
in this particular proof there's
different ways to do it and the way
we're gonna do it here I think is that
we can see that five and six see how
those angles are right across from each
other those two intersecting lines they
form two pairs of vertical angles so the
angles that are across from each other
when two lines intersect like that those
are called vertical angles and they're
congruent to each other so we know that
v is congruent to six and then we also
know that seven is congruent to eat
because those are vertical angles so now
what we can see it's starting to come
together
for us we can see that v is equal to six
six is equal to seven seven is equal to
eight why would v be equal to eight well
that's the transitive property so you
can think of the transitive property
kind of like a train like they're all
connected together like the cars of a
train but essentially if v is equal to
six and six equal to seven seven is
equal to eight and they're all equal to
each other so the first will naturally
be equal to the last so I think we have
a good framework now so then I would go
over here to the two column so I get the
statements and reasons and I would you
know hash it out
so basically step number one I always
like to write the Givens first not
everyone writes the Givens first a
matter of fact you know what maybe in
this proof we won't we
do it first okay a lot of times I just
like to do it and write it and get it
out of the way so don't forget about it
and you know it just gets me going with
the proof and then whatever you're
trying to prove you always want to make
that the last step okay and then you
want to fill in the in-between steps
that gets you from the beginning to the
end
you know sequentially so I think for the
first step let's just say that angle
five okay is congruent to angle six and
the reason for that would be vertical
angle theorem so I'm just abbreviating
here but you can write it out the
vertical angle theorem and then let's go
to step number two we know that six is
congruent to seven so we're going to say
angle six is congruent to angle seven
and the reason for that was that it was
given so I'm just gonna write given okay
so here with me so far
step number three we know that seven is
congruent to eight angle seven secured
to angle eight and again that's the
vertical angle theorem okay
vertical angle theorem and then the last
step number four is what we talked about
at the very beginning about using the
transitive property if v is equal to six
and six is equal to seven and seven is
equal to 8 v will be equal to eight okay
and that's what we were trying to prove
that's our last step and the reason
again was the transitive property
transitive property and that's it so
this is a beginning proof I hope this
helped you to understand a little bit
how to work through the proof some of
the hints and keys that I gave you there
check out some of the other geometry
proofs I'm going to have on my mario's
math tutoring YouTube channel and
subscribe to the channel take a look at
some of those videos and I look forward
to seeing in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon